good afternoon it is my pleasure to
introduce mr. Richard Brookhiser a
graduate of Yale University mr.
Brookhiser is a senior editor for
National Review where he has worked
since 1977 he has written for numerous
other publications including the New
York Observer and the Atlantic
he has also biographer and historian of
the founding period and the author of
several books including rediscovering
George Washington and most recently
found her son a life of Abraham Lincoln
he was awarded in 2008 the National
Medal of the humanities and in 2011 he
received a Guggenheim Fellowship please
join me in welcoming mr. Rickard
Richard Brookhiser
thank you thank you Bronte thank you
Matt thank you all for coming out here
in this I guess typical South Central
Michigan winter day I'm I'm very pleased
to be back at Hillsdale this is my my
fourth time here it's always good to be
here and good to see so many old friends
particularly for a journalism conference
my old friend and colleague professor
John Miller are there students of his
here in the journalism program yes okay
be like him and you'll do fine that's
that's my tip I'm going to talk this
afternoon about journalism and the
founding era journalism can do a lot for
good and for ill and in founding era
America they saw it all and I'm going to
talk about four journalists who
illustrate four aspects of journalism
those aspects are attacking amusing
instructing and inspiring and the four
journalists who show these qualities are
James Callender attack Benjamin Franklin
amusement Alexander Hamilton instruction
and Thomas Paine inspiration but before
I get to my journalists I just have to
explain a little bit about the world in
which they operate it when we're talking
about 18th century journalism we're
talking about print Telegraph's and
photographs are not developed until the
1840s and obviously everything wireless
is 20th century but the 18th century
does have print it has newspapers and it
also has pamphlets which are
freestanding articles cheaper to produce
than books
you could think of them as magazine
essays without the magazine although
some of them can be quite lengthy
America in the 18th century had an
unusually high number of newspapers I'm
not going to give you an exact figure
because the figure keeps growing
throughout the period but think in terms
of several dozen and constantly
expanding the interesting figure is the
contrast with other countries America
has more newspapers per capita in the
18th century than Britain and many more
per capita than France even though
Britain and France are the two super
powers in the world and we are a small
provincial X colonial country so how did
we how do we get so many of them part of
its geography our population is small
but it's very spread out its strung out
along the east coast and then it begins
to move into the interior there's no
equivalent to London or Paris
no metropolis that sucks people into it
so the population is dispersed and
therefore the newspapers are dispersed
this population is also surprisingly
literate the ultimate reason for that is
probably religious there were a number
of churches in colonial America which
were very keen on Bible reading so if
people were educated to be able to read
a Bible they were also able to read a
newspaper so there was a large potential
audience there now the founding fathers
were very aware of this media world a
number of them were part-time or
full-time professional journalists Sam
Adams published a newspaper a Benjamin
Franklin for much of his life was a
printer who published several different
newspapers at the end of his life
Alexander
founds and publishes a newspaper the New
York Evening Post which is still around
as the New York Post and Thomas
Jefferson and James Madison when
Jefferson is Secretary of State and
Madison as a congressman they start a
newspaper in Philadelphia which is the
nation's capital now neither Jefferson
nor Madison actually edits the paper but
Madison finds a man to edit it and
Jefferson gives him a part-time job in
the State Department to guarantee his
income so it'll be easier for him to
bring out this this newspaper that they
want want to get up and running almost
all the founding fathers write for
newspapers or write pamphlets at one
time or another and all of them read
newspapers one visitor to Mount Vernon
noticed that George Washington had
subscriptions to ten newspapers so these
men are very aware of this world very
involved in it one other point about it
is that all the newspapers have a point
of view they all express some sort of
partisan opinion and no one is bothered
by that I mean they will disagree with
that point of view but no one thinks oh
wouldn't it be nice if they're all
objective that's that's just not a goal
now you want your newspaper to be
informative because that makes it more
interesting and more useful but
everybody expects every newspaper to be
expressing a particular point of view so
that is the world that's the world of
journalism James Callender enters this
world from Scotland he starts off as a
young man in Scotland writing radical
pamphlets after the beginning of the
French Revolution in 1789 and this
causes a ferment
throughout the Atlantic world and
Britain very soon cracks down on it
because they don't want revolutionary
ideas spreading to Britain
so calendar decides in the early 1790s
it would be better and safer for him to
move to the United States he moves to
Philadelphia where he reports on debates
in Congress and there he meets the clerk
of the house who's a man named John
Buckley now at this time the the early
1790s America is developing its first
two-party system which will be the
Federalists of Alexander Hamilton versus
the Republicans of Jefferson and Madison
the Republicans would later become the
Democrats the Democratic Party of today
the modern Republican Party has nothing
to do with either either of these
parties and when we think of the
disputes that Hamilton on the one hand
had with Jefferson and Madison we think
of it as a battle of titans of founding
fathers disagreeing about financial
policy about the French Revolution about
the size and structure of government and
that's true but below these great men
there was a sub world almost an
underworld of assistants helpers gossips
snoops errand boys
journalists John Beckley is part of that
world
he works for Jefferson and Madison and
he spots calendar as a recruit for their
side a calendars first great scoop
happens in 1797 he writes a pamphlet
called a history of the United States
for the Year 1796
I wish I could I could quote from it but
it's impossible because no copies of it
exist it was a ferocious attack on
Alexander Hamilton and it seems as if
Hamilton and his family bought up every
copy they could find so none or none are
now left but it made a big splash when
it came out because calendar made the
charge
that Hamilton who he was now retired but
when he was treasury secretary he was
engaged in insider trading with a
small-time crook named James Reynolds
Hamilton would tip him off about
Treasury policies before they were
announced Reynolds would go out and make
trades and Hamilton paid Reynolds for
these services now in order to defend
himself Hamilton wrote a 95 page
pamphlet called observations on certain
documents where he admitted that he knew
James Reynolds he admitted that he'd
given Reynolds $1,000 during one year
when he was Treasury secretary but the
reason he paid him was not because of
insider trading but because he was
having an affair with Maria Reynolds
James's wife and James Reynolds had
blackmailed him and to prove this he
printed Maria's love letters James's
blackmail letters and an affidavit from
Maria's former landlord who remembered
her complaining to him that her husband
wanted to pimp her two prominent men and
Hamilton was the man they caught this
obviously created a sensation it
thrilled Hamilton's enemies it mortified
his allies he protected his reputation
for financial integrity his reputation
for common sense suffered so after this
calendar kept writing he got in various
scrapes then in 1800 Thomas Jefferson
wins a presidential election he'd run
against John Adams in 1796 and lost but
in the election of 1800 the Republican
Party beats the Federalist Party for the
presidency and it also takes in both
houses of Congress
it is a Republican sweep and now James
Callender thinks he should be rewarded
and he asked his friends and patrons
Jefferson and Madison if he could be a
postmaster somewhere
it seems as if Jefferson had become
suspicious of calendar that's it's not
clear but it is clear that calendar did
not get a postmaster ship this was a
mistake because calendar moved to
Richmond switched parties and opened a
federalist newspaper called the Richmond
recorder and there he made his second
scoop which I will be able to read to
you from and you've all heard of it you
all know this though you may not know
the specifics here's how the story began
this is September 1802 it is well known
that the man who met delighteth the
people to honor keeps and for many years
past has kept as his concubine one of
his own slaves her name is Sally Sally
Hemings the name of her eldest son is
Tom his features are said to bear a
striking though sable resemblance to
those of the President himself and it
goes on and on but I just want to
comment on that opening now this is
garbage this is character assassination
and politics of personal destruction but
it is well written you have to
understand this is well written
first there's the biblical allusion whom
it delight us the people to honor
everyone who read that would know that
this is a reference to the book of
Esther which is commemorated in the
Jewish holiday of Purim and the book of
Esther is about Jews and captivity in
Persia and the king of Persia has a
Jewish adviser named Mordecai and
Mordecai's adopted daughter Esther is
one of the Kings consorts but the king
has another advisor haman the agagite
who hates Mordecai and wants to destroy
all the Jews the King finds out about
this and he plays a trick on Haman he
summons him and asks him what is the
proper reward
for a man whom the king delighteth to
honor this is the source of calendars
reference Haman thinks he's talking
about himself so he suggests all sorts
of of nice things and then the King
reveals that he's actually thinking of
Mordecai the Haman realizes that the
wheel has turned and he is ultimately
executed and the Jews are given
permission to kill all his supporters
so what calendar is doing here
America doesn't have a king but it does
have the people and the people have just
elected Jefferson president so he is the
man whom it delight us the people to
honor but what calendar is suggesting is
after I get done with him he will be
like Haman then he goes on and we have
this wonderful choice of words in this
sentence where he says that Sally's son
Tom has a sable resemblance to Jefferson
now I could have said dark which would
have been good because that would
associate Jefferson with darkness but he
says sable and that gives this sentence
wonderful alliteration listen to all
these asses his features are said to
bear a striking those sable resemblance
to those of the President himself it's
like a hissing snake this is well done
stuff none the rest of the piece it
rambles a bit and then finally
calendared it's back in his stride at
the very end he says the allegation of a
nature too black to be suffered to
remain in suspense we should be glad to
hear of its refutation Federalists were
delighted with this story they reprinted
it
they wrote poems about it they drew
cartoons about it one famous cartoon
shows Jefferson and Sally Hemings as as
a pair of chickens Jefferson as the
rooster and the cartoon is captioned a
philosophic [ __ ] they played rough in
the 18th century they really took the
gloves off
another audience for the story later a
little later as abolitionists and they
tell the story to show that slavery is
such a wicked system that even the
author of the Declaration of
Independence which they Revere is caught
in its toils and behaves badly then a
third audience who loved this story were
Englishmen especially Englishmen
visiting America and who were constantly
told by Americans isn't this a great
democratic country unlike you with all
your kings and Lords and so on so they
liked using this story to turn it back
on Americans and Charles Dickens and the
Irish poet Thomas More both wrote about
Jefferson dreaming of freedom in his
slaves embrace and the story is still
with us
when recent DNA tests showed that
descendants of Sally Hemings had a
chromosome which is carried on the
Jefferson male line now that's not
hundred percent proof but I think the
burden of proof does rest now with those
who would say that the story is false
and we know about it not because of
historians or not even because of
high-end classy journalists but because
of this attack journalist James
Callender
for amusement the founding father who we
rightly think of as most amusing is
Benjamin Franklin Franklin could command
many tones of voice he could be the
scientist he could be the giver of good
advice early to bed early to rise makes
a man healthy wealthy and wise and he
had dozens of other sayings that he
printed in almanacs that we all know we
seemed to grow up knowing them but
Franklin's maybe his best most effective
voice is humor particularly in hoaxes
Franklin loves to print hoaxes pretended
essays for 10
as letters by people and he's the master
of the straight-faced because a hoax has
to be done exactly right if you push it
too hard it's too much if you don't
catch the the exact tone of what you're
imitating it won't work and the very
last piece of journalism that Franklin
writes when he's an old man almost 84
years old is a hoax it's his last hoax
and it's about slavery in the slave
trade the Constitution which has just
gone into effect in 1789 said that the
slave trade could not be forbidden
before 1808 this was the price of
Georgia and South of North Carolina
signing so that's in the Constitution
and the Constitution also said this
provision may not be amended so that was
a firm deal that had been made
nevertheless Quakers submitted a
petition to the first Congress asking
that the slave trade be ended the Quaker
religion had decided earlier in the
century that slavery was something no
Christian could participate in and
Quakers many Quakers had become early
abolitionists so they they submitted a
petition to Congress and they called the
constitutional prohibition a seeming
impediment while Congress obviously has
to reject their petition they don't they
don't have the power to accept it but
one of the speeches on it is by
representative James Jackson of Georgia
now he had come to this country when he
was 15 years old in 1772 he'd fought in
the revolution and now he was a
congressman and he criticizes the Quaker
petition not just on the grounds of its
unconstitutionality but he comes very
close now he actually he crosses the
line he defends slavery itself this is
what he said in Conroe
why do these men set themselves up in
such a particular manner against slavery
do they understand the rights of mankind
and the disposition of Providence better
than others if they were to consult the
Bible they will find that slavery is not
only allowed but commended if they fully
examine the subject they will find that
slavery has been no novel doctrine since
the days of Cain well this was all
Franklin needed to get going so he wrote
a letter to a Philadelphia newspaper and
it begins this way it's not obviously
signed Ben Franklin it's signed historic
Asst historian and Latin to the editor
of the Federal Gazette sir reading last
night in your excellent paper of the
speech of mr. Jackson and Congress
against meddling with the affair of
slavery it put me in mind of a similar
one made about 100 years since by c/d
Muhammad Ibrahim a member of the divan
of Algiers which may be seen in Martin's
account of his consulship published in
1687 it was against granting a petition
for the abolition of piracy and slavery
as being unjust mr. Jackson does not
quote it perhaps he has not seen it if
therefore some of its reasonings are to
be found in his eloquent speech it may
only show that men's interests operate
with surprising similarity in all
countries and climates whenever they are
under similar circumstances the African
speech as translated is as follows now
before I get to the Africans speech a
couple of points first the tone you all
recognize the tone of this this is the
slightly pompous letter to the editor
we've all read those letters maybe we've
written some of them but I mean here he
writes he has a historical comparison he
has the name he has a book that you can
look up
he he says oh yes he yes he gives the
book it's Martin's account of his
consulship so evidently Martin sounds
like an English and Englishman an
English diplomat who would have been a
consul to Algiers and he wrote this book
in the 17th century now after this
letter was published the people went to
book stores in Philadelphia asking for
Martin's account of his consulship they
didn't have much luck since there is no
such book and then Franklin goes on he
says mr. Jackson does not quote it
perhaps he has not seen it well of
course he hasn't seen it Benjamin
Franklin is making it all up so and then
then finally he says the Africans speech
as translated as as follows now of
course that's this very subtle dig
because Algiers is in northern Africa so
that is Africa but sub-saharan Africa is
where all the slaves of Georgia and of
Representative Jackson come from so he's
kind of slyly equating Jackson's
arguments with African arguments now
here's the speech that he quotes the
African speech as translated as as
follows all of the smaller God is great
and Muhammad is His Prophet
how grossly are they mistaken in
imagining slavery to be disallowed by
the al-quran are not the two precepts
masters treat your slaves with kindness
slaves serve your masters with
cheerfulness and fidelity clear proofs
to the contrary nor can the plundering
of infidels be in that sacred book
forbidden since it is well known from it
that God has given the world and all
that it contains to his faithful
muscleman who are to enjoy it of right
as fast as they can conquer it let us
then hear no more of this detestable
proposition now Franklin is not just
just drawing any comparison from any
part of the world here
he's talking about Algiers in the 17th
century but Algiers is one of the
Barbary States these were four countries
in North Africa Morocco Algiers Tunis
and Tripoli and in both the 17th and
18th century and into the 19th century
these countries live by piracy and
slavery the arrangement was if you paid
them every year they would leave your
shipping alone you meaning Christian
countries of Europe but if you didn't
they would raid your ships and sell
everyone they captured into slavery it
was a religious extortion racket that
they ran and this is a current problem
when Franklin is writing the United
States would fight two wars with the
Barbary States early in the 19th century
when Jefferson was president then when
Madison was president Franklin is
writing 25 years before that so he's
writing about an issue that is an
ongoing international problem and then
he adds he quotes some more of this
speech and says the result was as Martin
tells us that the divan came to the
resolution let the petition be rejected
and it was rejected accordingly I am sir
your constant reader and humble servant
historic as' now he's he's not just
doing this to have fun he's doing it to
to try and change people's perceptions
he's really saying if you can't see the
evil of slavery here because it's ours
and that's so close to us then look at
it over there where the slaves are our
Christian white man and then maybe
you'll see the evil of it there I don't
know that it had any effect on
representative Jackson but it it did
raise a laugh when it was printed in
Philadelphia for instruction
if we think of the founding fathers and
instruction we have to think of
Alexander Hamilton because he is the
great know-it-all of the founding
fathers he not only believed that he was
one of the only people in the country
who understood modern finance and
economics he was probably right about
that he also believed that he understood
everything else and he would be happy to
tell you what he understood and how you
could do your job probably better than
you were doing it I think this is this
is one of the personal sources of the
first two-party system it was about
ideology it was about issues but frankly
Hamilton's personality had a lot to do
with it because some people appreciated
his omniscience and other people really
disliked it including Thomas Jefferson
Hamilton was a journalist all his life
his first piece was written when he was
14 years old living in the Caribbean
which is where he came from a terrible
hurricane hit st. Croix which was which
was where he was living at the time he
described it in a letter to his father
and then it was published in a st. Croix
newspaper and after it came out a to two
local figures decided this is a bright
young man we have to send him to the
mainland to be educated now Hamilton was
in effect an orphan at the time because
his mother had died and although he was
writing his father his father had taken
off abandoned his family just moved
moved elsewhere so the men who helped
him were his boss Hamilton was a clerk
an accounting house and a local minister
and the plan was to send him to the 13
colonies he would become educated and
then he'd come back to the islands as a
doctor and the first plan was to send
him to Princeton that didn't work out so
he ended up going to Kings College which
is now Columbia he never graduated
because the American Revolution started
and he quit to fight in a
and then his career took off in the path
that it would follow but Hamilton
continued to write journalism while he
was in college while he was a soldier
and after the war when he starts getting
into law and into politics and the
greatest of his projects was the
Federalist Papers the Constitution was
of course discussed and written in
Philadelphia in the summer of 1787 and
when we think of debates over the
Constitution we often think of those
debates in that Hall that's partly
because we have a very detailed account
of them left by James Madison but we
have to remember that those debates were
secret no one except the delegates knew
anything about them until years later
Madison's notes were not published until
after he died in 1840
so the debates over the Constitution
that mattered were not those debates but
the ones that occurred at the state
ratifying conventions and in the
newspapers of the United States from the
fall of 1787 to the fall of 1788 when
the Constitution is finally ratified and
New York City New York State is a center
of opposition to the Constitution New
York sent three delegates to the
convention Hamilton was one of them but
the other two left halfway through
because they were disgusted with what
was going on and one of them Robert
Yates wrote a series of anti
Constitution essays very very quickly he
signed them Brutus and he made a number
of powerful arguments the first one was
why is there no bill of rights in this
constitution and he made it very subtly
because he says the Constitution does
guarantee habeas corpus and it forbids
bills of attainder so if they put that
in there why didn't they put in freedom
of religion freedom of speech no cruel
and unusual punishment why are there
none of our other rights
he also makes a very powerful argument
that republics cannot be large we can't
have a national Republican government in
this country because it's already too
big and his example is Rome look at Rome
Rome started as a city but then it
conquered the whole Mediterranean and at
that point it changed from a republic to
an empire republics have to be small so
Alexander Hamilton who's now back in New
York he sees the effect that Brutus is
having and he he knows the Constitution
has to have a media campaign and its
support and being Hamilton he gets one
going he finds two collaborators James
Madison another delegate to the
convention and John Jay the former
diplomat and spymaster who's an older
man there are five newspapers in New
York City at the time Hamilton arranges
for their essays to be run in all five
of them he wanted market saturation the
essays came out at the rate of four a
week some weeks there were five one week
there were six these essays are each two
thousand words long
a typical op-ed piece today 750 words
this was a brutal temper and when
Madison was an old man he remembered
that you know when we started writing
these things we we'd show our
collaborators our first draft but it
just became so rapid we couldn't do that
anymore so each man was was in it for
himself and and several times the
printers messenger would be at someone's
door while he was still finishing up a
federalist essay Jay started off with
four then he got sick then about
two-thirds of the way through he wrote
another one then he was injured in a
riot so he only ended up writing five
Madison wrote 29 Hamilton wrote 51 for
85 essays and all
and they covered every aspect of the
Constitution they didn't quite answer
the question of the Bill of Rights
Hamilton wrote wrote of a rather
interesting argument but it was not
effectual they did demolish the argument
that Republic's have to be small
probably the most famous argument now is
is Madison's where he says that in a
large republic there will be so many
conflicting interests that no one of
them will overwhelm all the others
whereas in a small one that would be
easier to happen but Hamilton also made
an economic argument he said that the
thirteen colonies naturally trade with
each other and profit from each other
and Jay made maybe the strongest
argument of all he said if we have
thirteen states or three Confederations
ordering each other they'll be
constantly at war and European powers
will be pitting them against each other
and there'll be standing armies so
Madison is making an argument from
politics Hamilton was making one from
economics Jay made one for peace but
what I want to read you now is just from
the first paragraph of the first
Federalist it's Hamilton and this is
about the whole project and it's really
a statement of the best of democratic
politics Hamilton says to the people of
the state of New York it seems to have
been reserved to the people of this
country to decide the important question
whether societies of men are really
capable or not of establishing good
government from reflection and choice or
whether they are forever destined to
depend for their political constitutions
on accident and force can we have good
government from reflection and choice or
must we forever depend on accident and
force
he's asking you to think of history and
he'll go on to be very specific
kicking off examples but here he's just
introducing it think of history
revolutions assassinations civil wars we
could go through that again but we can
do something different we can reflect
and then we can choose and then he goes
on I frankly acknowledge to you my
convictions
that's the Hamilton no you know I I
figured this out then he says I will
freely lay before you the reasons on
which they are founded that's also the
Hamilton note he was a know-it-all but
he never said agree with me because I
say so
he always said agree with me because
here are my reasons I think it for this
and this and this he said I will tell
you all my reasons my friends and I'll
write 85 essays if you want and when
were done you will know everything I
know he was a know-it-all but he was a
very generous no at all and that's the
best statement of the spirit of
democratic politics trusting your
electorate trusting your audience
sharing with them what you think what
you know for inspirate well oh no before
I leave the Federalist Papers of course
it had an effect in New York probably
also in Virginia was reprinted there but
maybe one of the best judgments on it
the Marquis de Talleyrand who was a wily
French diplomat he had to live for two
years in the United States France got a
little hot for him so he he took a
little sabbatical in the United States
where one of his friends was Hamilton
whom he greatly admired and then when he
was back and in France running things
there from behind the scenes a Spanish
diplomat remarked to him that he'd never
he'd never read the Federalist Papers
and talleyrand the old fox just said
read it read it
finally inspiration and the the
journalists to exemplifies this is
Thomas Paine Paine is another immigrant
you'll see that three of these four
people are our immigrants and I think
that's because journalism pulls for
outsiders a pain as an Englishman he had
a kind of a various life in England he
was a corset maker he was a tax
collector he was a privateer
but then in 1774 he comes to the United
States and there he finds himself as a
journalist his first great hit is a
pamphlet in early 1776 common sense and
this is an argument for America
declaring independence we've already
been fighting Britain for eight months
but but we've done it still professing
loyalty to the king it's only Parliament
and the Kings ministers we say that we
are fighting and pain rights common
sense to say it's past that point it's
really past that point we should declare
our independence but his greatest moment
comes at the end of that year in
December of 1776 the second half of that
year was a disaster for the American
cause the British decided to attack New
York make that their base Washington
loses the Battle of Long Island in
Brooklyn then the British land on
Manhattan they drive him steadily off
the island
he loses the Battle of White Plains in
October he's left one garrison in
northern Manhattan Fort Washington it's
now inward Park there are 3,000 men in
that fortress Nathaniel Greene tells
Washington it can be defended but Greene
is wrong the British take it in all
3,000 men
Washington is watching this across the
Hudson River in New Jersey and one man
said he wept like a child
when he saw what was happening the
British crossed the Hudson pursued him
through New Jersey he was losing
soldiers his soldiers had no shoes no
adequate clothing you could follow the
line of his retreat by the blood of
their footprints now this one gloriously
with the victories of Trenton and
Princeton at the end of the year but
they didn't know that in the middle of
December and Thomas Paine is living in
in Philadelphia he comes to the army in
New Jersey to to follow it and report on
its progress and he writes an essay he
writes it on a drum head by campfire
light then he goes back to Philadelphia
to get it printed and it's called the
American crisis and it has I think the
best lead in the history of journalism
here it is these are the times that try
men's souls the summer soldier and the
sunshine patriot will in this crisis
shrink from the service of their country
but he that stands at now deserves the
love and thanks a man and woman tyranny
like hell is not easily conquered yet we
have this consolation with us that the
harder the conflict the more glorious
the triumph
what we obtain too cheap we esteem too
lightly it is dearness only that gives
everything its value heaven knows how to
put a proper price upon its goods and it
would be strange indeed is so celestial
an article as freedom should not be
highly rated I don't know if Paine was
was thinking of Shakespeare when he
wrote that I I think of King Harry's
speech before the Battle of Agincourt
and Henry v where he says this band this
happy band this band of brothers and
every man that fights with me this day
shall gentle his condition shall become
a gentle moment the pain is writing the
Republic
come equivalent of that you're not going
to become gentlemen for doing this
you're going to earn the love and the
thanks of man and woman of your
neighbors of your peers I don't know
what to say about this this is this is
so eloquent I don't see how it can
possibly be improved and and the peace
goes on it can't it doesn't maintain
quite that level of how could it but
there is another very moving moment
towards the end where pain is talking
about a Tory an opponent of the
revolution whom he who's a tavern keeper
in New Jersey and he says he was
standing at a store with this pretty a
child in his hand about eight or nine
years old as I ever saw and after
speaking his mind to finished with this
unfairly expression well give me peace
in my day so he's saying why why are we
having this revolution it's not worth it
give me peace in my day and then Payne
says a generous parent should have said
if there must be trouble let it be in my
day that my child may have peace now
pain is a little wrong because of course
children will all have their own
troubles but he's right because let's
not pass ours to our children and if we
have to fight to solve them let's do
that so what became of these men these
journalists the first to die was
Benjamin Franklin 1790 just some months
after his little hoax at representative
Jackson's expense he was covered with
honors and everybody loved him the
second one to die was James Callender
ten months after he wrote about Sally
Hemings he drowned in the James River in
three feet of water now if you were
insulted in those days by a gentleman
you could
challenge him to a duel the dueling was
illegal everywhere but it was never
prosecuted because juries would not
convict but journalists were mostly not
gentlemen so you didn't challenge them
to duels you could beat them up and pain
had been beaten with a club a few weeks
before that by son-in-law of James
Monroe the coroner's jury ruled that his
drowning was accidental the next one to
die was Alexander Hamilton in 1804 he
did die in a duel who shot and killed by
the vice-president of the United States
a journalism was involved in it because
a letter had appeared in an upstate
newspaper about a dinner party of
Federalists and the letter writer said
there was some criticism of vice
president Burr and Hamilton said that he
could give a still more despicable
opinion of him now Hamilton and burr had
been fighting politically for years they
were both New Yorkers both lawyers they
knew each other but burr always seemed
worse to Hamilton than Jefferson I think
in a funny way he trusted Jefferson he
knew what Jefferson would do and from
his point of view most of it would be
wrong but Jefferson was predictable he
thought Jefferson was honest and he
thought Jefferson was a cautious man
from Hamilton's point of view Jefferson
would always talk a worse game and he
would do but Burr he never trusted he
thought there was something Napoleonic
about burr so there was a different edge
to the things he said about him sober
reads this letter in the Upstate
newspaper he asks for an explanation of
the two gentlemen met at a dueling
ground in New Jersey
Hamilton shot mist burr hit Hamilton and
the liver and lodged in his spine took
him 36 hours to die and I've seen the
front page of the New York Post of that
evening and there's a little box truck
the front page it's like a news flash or
the crawler on a CNN screen and it says
Hamilton injured in a duel and the next
day he died and the last one to die was
was Thomas Payne after our revolution he
goes to France and gets involved in it's
he's elected to the French National
Assembly even though he hardly speaks
any French he votes to depose louis xvi
and to set up a republic but he argues
against executing him and his argument
is that louis xvi has grown up in a
royal world what else did he ever know
we should send him to America and he can
live under a Republican government maybe
he'll improve as a person this argument
is not persuasive Payne was arrested he
was slated for execution the only reason
he was not guillotine is that they
passed his cell by accident the day he
was to be killed but then there's a
change in the wheel of politics and he's
released he comes back to America in
1802 by this time he's drinking heavily
and he dies poor in Greenwich Village in
1809
so journalism can do great things but
journalists don't necessarily have great
lives thank you very much
we have a few minutes for questions we
have microphones coming to Rove please
raise your hand and stand also please
speak up and keep the question shorter
than the answer might be and let me also
mention that right after the Q&A session
mr. Brooke Kaiser has agreed to sign
copies of the founders a founders son a
life of Abraham Lincoln his newest book
over here just on this level by the
staircase okay any questions
great I've explained it all oh yes there
we go
yes sir regarding dr. Franklin I have
read well he wrote a fictitious letter
which was his style all the way from
silence do-good
they're called the tobacco letter in
which he used psychological warfare to
convince Hessians to desert so far from
what I've read this is all speculation
I'd like your comment if if indeed this
is this was written by dr. Franklin or
not it has his fingerprints all over it
and to divulge the actual author would
would absolutely nullify any good that
it would do as far as well he wrote so
so many of these hoaxes like I cannot
keep track of them all his works are
published so so you can look in there he
did keep it up during the Revolution he
was sent to France as a diplomat he
lived outside of Paris and but he set up
a printing press in his house where he
where he churned out articles and some
of them are humorous pieces but he also
wrote political pieces attacks on
British condom
and also hoaxes of the kind you're
talking about so it certainly sounds
like him I simply don't know but but the
complete works are out there so I'm not
not so hard to chase down yes sir oh
there we go
sir thank you very much for your time
today my question is going to be going
back to your talk about James Callender
and that type of investigative reporting
how does that relate to contemporary
press coverage if you could just respond
a little bit on that from the evolution
of freedom of the press from that period
in history into today's modern era thank
you sir
well I mean look they're obvious they're
obvious similarities you know calendar
he had his two big scoops involved sex
scandals I mean the one he elicited from
Hamilton and then the other he simply
tied tried to tie to Jefferson's tale
and you know and heaven knows we we
wallow in this stuff we've been you know
the Clinton years sort of sort of opened
the floodgates and on and on it goes
there is something disreputable about
journalism there is and it's always
there and it will never go away I mean
John I hope I'm not corrupting your
students but but you know this this is
an aspect of it journalists tell things
that people don't want known although we
like to read them you know and a lot of
those things are misbehavior so this is
just in the mix it's never going to
disappear you know and the journalists I
David Brooks he recently was on some TV
show and he talked about well there's
the adult table in the kiddie table of
journalism I thought you know David's an
old friend of mine when I thought oh
geez David I mean come on you know the
kiddies are all over the place and yeah
and sometimes adults behave like them
and sometimes the kiddies grow up so
that's that's journalism and it's never
going to change its spots entirely
Thank You mr. Brookhiser the four
aspects that you mentioned are there
journalists today or in the recent past
that you would beside us examples as
amusing inspiring attacking
instructional well I'm just going to
talk about the 18th century sorry
speaking of instructive
James Madison certainly was in that
category not only because he
collaborated with Hamilton in the
Federalist but because he and Hamilton
were in dueling writing dueling essays
in the 1790s be careful how you use the
word dueling yeah yeah
journalistic dueling right in any event
which was quite an informative period
you know Hamilton started the National
Gazette I'm sorry because they're the
United States with Jonathan was the
editor and then Madison Hamilton County
was the National present' so that was a
war going on earlier administration I
well through the Washington
administration so I'd just like you to
comment on the significance of that well
you know Doris Kearns Goodwin wrote this
this very good book about the Lincoln
administration which she called team of
rivals and that phrase has become sort
of like a management mantra hasn't it I
mean you just see it a lot and and
people think of that oh you know that's
the way to run my company I should get
like four or five people who hate each
other and completely disagree and then
it'll be great you know but the first
team of rivals was the Washington
administration it was not supposed to be
that way no one thought it would be that
way it only became so over time and
partly because of Hamilton's personality
partly because the French Revolution had
and in washington is inaugurated in
april of 1789 and the bastille falls in
july so when he's first thinking of his
cabinet this is not you know this is not
on his table and then just the issues of
setting up a government and how it
should be set up and it was hell for all
of them i mean it was just hell for them
and it's a tribute you know to
Washington's leadership and to his skill
that he kept these guys in the same tent
as long as he did
I mean he worked to keep Thomas
Jefferson in his job as Secretary of
State
long after Jefferson had turned against
the Washington administration and was
subsidizing this newspaper which
attacked the Washington administration
but Washington figured you know keep
your enemies close and so he G he just
he he worked and worked and finally
Jefferson left but it was a brilliant
job he kept him on much longer than you
would have thought and also this was all
new I think one one reason for the
frenzy of politics in the 1790 some some
historian called it the age of passion
is that it was brand new and now we know
you know if you lose you're gonna have
another chance in four years or eight
years and no party has ever run out of
town they didn't know that because this
was brand new and they knew the
Constitution they'd written and they you
know and they said they knew the laws
that they had passed but you you don't
believe in them until you have
experience of them so so Federalists
truly thought that the Republicans might
set up guillotines if they want and the
Republicans truly thought that Hamilton
was a monarchist you know there's both
nonsensical Thomas Jefferson was not
going to set up guillotines he praised
them in France but he had no intention
of setting them up here and Hamilton was
not a monarchist he fought against him
our key in the revolution so so both
sides had these Mis apprehensions of the
other and its really well then of course
we did have a civil war in the 1860s but
it takes a lot of experience before a
country realizes that it's unlikely that
it will tear itself apart and it's
unlikely that the winners will simply
crush the losers so that that was
something it was even more than wisdom
at torque and even more than genius it
took experience to live that lesson one
more we have time for one more question
you mentioned earlier in your speech
that back then the newspapers were all
clearly biased and everybody knew that
every newspaper they read at a point of
view what do you think about the
strengths and weaknesses of that system
and how effective it was compared to
what we have today well I kind of like
it
it's more it's more straightforward and
the newspapers did have information I
mean it wasn't all screeds all the time
they you know they would report on the
shipping news and they tell you about
the battles in Europe and they'd report
the doings of Congress and and and
that's also a selling point right I mean
you that's that's interesting
information that's useful your readers
want to know it you want to supply it so
so they did get the information out in
the news out and then they they had
their point of view and people you know
people knew what it was and expected it
so you know I think this is the system
worked pretty well I think I've
indicated that the lows of journalism
were lower than they are now they really
were but the highs were higher I mean we
had we had Thomas Paine at his best and
you know the Federalist Papers were
running as op eds and I think that's
that's a pretty good credit to the
founding era okay thank you very much